10:15 er every bar restaurant pops close
at 6:00 p.m. you can still go outside to
buy food you can go to cross grocery you
can go at a bakery just one person at a
time inside the shop you can't go
shopping in malls if your girlfriend or
boyfriend lives in another city you
can't go to visit him or her you can go
to help your elder parents or
grandfathers but just if you really need
to and if they seek help if they're fine
you can go to visit them you can still
get a bus on a bus to go to work
still the local government has asked a
premier country to ban all non-essential
activity for the next 15 days in that
case public transportation will be
halted but as you can see at the moment
there's not many people on on the line
to wait for a bus for the moment you can
still go to the barber shop but you have
to book your appointment and just one
person a time can be inside the barber
shop with a barber shop also you can
still go to work but if you really have
to be physically in the office work from
home is strongly recommended at the
moment you can get outside your place
for
okay thank you all very much for being
here let me begin by reiterating what I
have said from day one of this campaign
and that is that Donald Trump is the
most dangerous president in the modern
history of our country and he must be
defeated tragically we have a president
today who is a pathological liar and it
was running a corrupt administration he
clearly does not understand the
Constitution of the United States and
thinks that he is a president who is
above the law in my view he is a racist
a sexist a homophobe a xenophobe and a
religious bigot and he must be defeated
and I will do everything in my power to
make that happen
last night obviously was not a good
night for our campaign from a delegate
point of view we lost in the largest
state of programs yesterday state of
Michigan we lost in Mississippi Missouri
and Idaho on the other hand we won in
North Dakota and we lead the boat count
in the state of Washington the second
largest state contested yesterday with
67% of the votes have you been counted
we are a few thousand votes on top what
became even more apparent yesterday is
that wild we are currently losing the
delegate count approximately 800
delegates for Joe Biden and 660 for us
we are strongly winning in two enormous
ly important areas which will determine
the future of our country poll after
poll including exit polls show that a
strong majority of the American people
support our progressive agenda the
American people are deeply concerned
about the grotesque level of income and
wealth inequality in this country and
the American people want the wealthy and
large profitable corporations to start
paying their fair share of taxes
overwhelming support for that the
American people understand that the
federal minimum wage of 725 an hour is a
starvation wage they want to raise the
minimum wage in this country to a living
wage of at least $15 an hour and the
American people understand that our kids
are gonna make it into the middle class
of this country we must make public
colleges and universities and trade
schools tuition free the American people
understand that we cannot continue a
cruel and dysfunctional healthcare
system and it is amazing to me to see
that even in conservative states like
Mississippi there is an overwhelming
understanding that we are now spending
twice as much per capita on health care
as through the people of any other
country while 87 million of us remain
uninsured or underinsured and this
crisis this absurd health care system is
becoming more and more obvious to the
American people as we face the challenge
of the corona virus pandemic that we are
currently experiencing imagine facing a
pandemic and having 87 million people
who are having a difficult time going to
a doctor when they need and the American
people know unlike Donald Trump that
climate change is an existential threat
to our country in the planet and then we
need to transform our energy system away
from fossil fuel to energy efficiency
and sustainable energy and the American
people also know that we need
fundamental transformation of
broken and racist criminal justice
system as well as a cruel immigration
system that keeps millions of people
living in fear but it is not just the
ideological debate that our progressive
movement is waiting we are winning the
generational debate while Joe Biden
continues to do very well with older
Americans especially those people over
65 our campaign continues to win the
vast majority of the votes of younger
people and I am talking about people not
just in their 20s but in their 30s and
their 40s the younger generations of
this country continue in very strong
numbers to support our campaign today I
say to the Democratic establishment in
order to win in the future you need to
win the voters who represent the future
of our country and you must speak to the
issues of concern to them you cannot
simply be satisfied by winning the votes
of people who are oldham while our
campaign has won the ideological debate
we are losing the debate over
electability I cannot tell you how many
people our campaign has spoken to who
have said my quotes I like what your
campaign stands for I agree with what
your campaign stands for but I'm gonna
vote for Joe Biden because I think Joe
is the best candidate to defeat Donald
Trump
end of quote we have heard that
statement all over this country
needless to say I strongly disagree with
that assertion but that is what millions
of Democrats
and independence today belief on Sunday
I very much look forward to the debate
in Arizona with my friend Joe Biden and
let me be very frank as to the questions
that I will be asking Joe Joe what are
you gonna do for the 500,000 people who
go bankrupt in our country because of
medically related debt and what are you
gonna do for the working people of this
country and small businesspeople who are
paying on average 20 percent of their
incomes the health care Joe what are you
gonna do to end the absurdity of the
United States of America being the only
major country on earth where health care
is not a human right are you really
going to veto a medicare-for-all bill if
it is passed in Congress Joe how are you
gonna respond to the scientists who tell
us we have seven or eight years
remaining to transform our energy system
before irreparable harm takes place to
this planet because of the ravages of
climate change Joe at a time when most
young people need a higher education to
make it into the middle class what are
you going to do to make sure that all of
our people can go to college or trade
school regardless of their income and
what are you gonna do about the millions
of people who are struggling with
outrageous levels of student debt Joe at
a time when we have more people in jail
than Communist China a nation four times
our size what are you going to do to end
mass incarceration and a racist criminal
justice system and what are you going to
do to end the terror that millions of
undocumented people experience right now
because of our broken and
humane immigration system so what are
you gonna do about the fact that we have
the highest rate of childhood poverty of
almost any major country on earth and
are living with the fact that 500,000
people tonight are homeless and 18
million families are spending half of
their income to put a roof over their
heads so importantly what are you gonna
do to end the absurdity of billionaires
buying elections and the three
wealthiest people in America owning more
wealth than the bottom half of our
people so let me conclude the way I
began Donald Trump must be defeated and
I will do everything in my power to make
that happens on Sunday night in the
first one-on-one debate of this campaign
the American people will have the
opportunity to see which candidate is
best positioned to accomplish that goal
thank you all very you need to do better
with black voters the problem in Libya
is that there are too many children with
heart disease for one surgeon afraid on
their cardiologist spread out all over
the country there's only one surgeon you
only know about 300 cases a year so
after the Revolution we came in and we
started working in these I think that if
you look at the number of children that
we've been able operate since we've been
here
it's now up to around 1,000
on both sides of the country we're on
both sides of the conflict zone and that
is a cific goal are we able to help each
other you can create a sort of medical
diplomacy between the two sides of the
country utilizing the children with
heart disease as the issue to bring them
together over training is critical for
these individuals because whenever be
here forever
and we shouldn't be your fruit we should
be leaving behind independent
sustainable operating games and care
games and that's what we're trying to do
so we believe that by showing up by
being apolitical by taking care of the
children by providing education we can
show people in these other countries
where the perception of the American
might not be so good but guess what
people in the United States not
necessarily who can bridge the gap and
bringing cultures together
you
[Music]